hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of our readers Judith who was
considered getting into network
marketing after a friend introduced her
to a certain product and wanted my
advice on what to do so Judith thank you
for the question I don't have any
experience with that product that you
mentioned so you know can't give you a
thumbs up or thumbs down in terms of
network marketing I don't have a lot of
personal experience and most of the
stuff that I've done has been selling my
own product or my own services and
that's where I tend excel but I do have
a lot of friends I know people who have
had success with network marketing so
don't want to trash it as a business I
think the key thing to keep in mind with
network marketing is most of the money
that you make isn't going to come from
selling the product or service itself
it's more from your downline so
recruiting people to sell under you and
educating them on how to sell it so it's
good for you to know how to sell it
yourself so that when you are bringing
people on underneath you you can train
them and work with them to help them
sell better but most of the money you're
going to make is it from the actual
Commission's it's going to be from your
downline selling more so in order to do
that you got to think you know do you
have a network of people that you can
sell to are you going to be good at
training them on how to sell it or
you're just going to sign them up and
let them go do whatever they want to do
usually it doesn't work very well and so
they'll do you enjoy that process as
well are you the type of person who
wants to go out and talk to friends talk
to other people and try to get them to
sell this part of the service for you at
the end of the day I though I think that
the biggest factor is going to be are
you passionate about this product or
service that you're selling and that's
for me the bottom line most successful
entrepreneurs you'll find started
because I really love what they're doing
they feel like they have been a really
strong impact and they love the prompt
service that they're selling it's really
hard to get excited about a product if
you don't really believe in what it does
or if you're not and
avid user yourself if you mean it just
for the money because you think you can
make great commissions you're probably
not going to be really successful the
successful people come when they are
super passionate and are using a product
or service and really believe in it that
makes it easy to sell then you're not
really selling you just share your
experiences and your passion comes
through because they can see that you're
using it and you're really excited about
it so this product that you mentioned to
me you know are you using it you find it
valuable have you implemented it into
your own life and can you share personal
experiences about it or not you know if
no I would probably say no through the
opportunity and maybe look for something
else it could still be with the network
marketing but make sure that you are
passionate about that product that you
end up selling so hopefully that helps
good luck let me know if you end up you
know taking that opportunity or not for
those watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up but love
seeing those come in and if you have any
thoughts reviews as well be great to
hear what you have to say associate you
had some experience in network marketing
please leave a comment below and we'll
see you on the next episode
you
you